[Applause]
[Music]
shot in the eye with a suspected rubber
bullet
a baby too young to speak
but that's no protection from military
violence
in myanmar you can see the terror on the
family's faces
while their baby is alive
today the parents of other children are
mourning
myanmar's army has continued to
slaughter its people
turning the country's weapons against
them
weapons it today paraded in the capital
as the junta celebrated armed forces day
the general in charge warned violent
acts affects stability
and promised to protect the people and
strive for democracy
the same democracy which was crushed by
the coup
he led the same people which his
security forces are now killing
[Music]
disgusted by the bloodshed the chief of
one of the country's rebel armies in
shan
state issued a stark
horrified by the mounting death toll the
un
and countries including britain again
denounced the violence
but after almost two months of killing
the pressure for urgent intervention is
growing
robbins sky news bangkok